[Musique]
et ce vendredi la preuve qu'en 2018
on peut encore vivre dans un extrême
dénuement à la réunion à l'île est
bananiers à salazie jean yves plante
habite dans une case ouverte à tous les
vents sans eau ni électricité
l'association un moment papa lé là veut
aujourd'hui à lui venir en aide il lance
un appel
jean marc collienne et laurent fignon le
rencontrer pour cette nouvelle séquence
de vie
[Musique]
et
il
on y est
hé hé
il dit
c'est un homme de 53 ans qui a toujours
connu la misère depuis une vingtaine
d'années
vi dans cette carte
à cause de graves problèmes de santé
opération au genou et hernie abdominale
il n'a plus aucune activité
début toujours ajournées que le café
j'arrive
bah oui bon petit café le matin comme
élève avocat fait doucement
blackmont y vivent là
ou deux villas aujourd'hui et comment
pour mesurables dans une situation
pareille
- avant dans un sol en béton une case en
tôle délabré envahi par les carrés à et
qui menace de s'effondrer
jean-yves vit depuis des années dans des
conditions extrêmement précaires
lapointe l'électricité non le tai chi
témoin et le frigo alors le frigo y
mange pas c'est un but we go monte à
bout de bricolage le petit bonbon un
point du poids insu mon père viendra de
fouet après deux tours oui voilà comment
me donne
je l'obligé deux chiens un vieux matelas
c'est à 15 ou l'a fait ces marchés va
découper m'a pointé mujika doucement
doucement
il tient beaucoup à la pinto mais quand
la pluie tombe mines et de l'eau
delecourt par atos et sis la cicrane
même obligé ce qu en fait commencé la
bête mais qu'un mouvement d'un coin
cachette d'un coin n'a pas dormi
il fallait gagner du lot la belle manne
là les moyens de la nuit' jean-yves n'a
pas l'électricité
il n'a pas l'eau courante non plus il a
juste bricoler une arrivée d'eau de
source
mais il n'a ni wc ni celle de bain au
lendemain matin miller
il a brassé médiévale et quand il ya eu
la mise in et un bébé point est bon
parce qu'elle loue le show est l'ami
larmont lège là
au cabinet les hauts fonds en bas
voilà à mon cabinet la mairie doucement
quatre attaques mais lui je ne joue mal
comme héros là même leur douleur ces
autres terrasses oui oui on apprend des
petits piments depuis pieds sont des
petits pieds de tomates abuse des petits
animaux sont là
tout ça c'est vous qui l'a fait ben oui
le parcours c'est moi a fait des petits
piments les 11 à moi mais quand même pu
gratter mais en lui même peut occuper
[Musique]
pas mal mais bernard le voisin vient
souvent rendre visite à jean yves
les deux hommes se connaissent depuis
qu'ils sont enfants amazighs manhattan
cela y arriver là je fais jamais écrit
la jeune est bien mais en iowa - c'est
un petit peu lent mais j'ai une typique
du minho nikon écoutent la radio
première mais voilà pendant la journée
passe comme ça et parfois ou déprime un
peu je déprime parce que au monde et par
engin comment les deux mois se passer
jean-yves n'arrête pas de le ressasser
abandonné à l'âge de 2 mois par ses
parents il a été confié à l'assistance
publique puis placé dans une famille
d'accueil
adolescent il a vécu dans la rue puis il
est revenu à salazie travailler sur le
terrain de ses grands parents j'ai la
propriété au dessus de voir marié
d'abord encore au fil des mois mais tous
ces territoires à la basse et un maigre
en élaboration
et il m'a fait 10 ans là bas c'est
encore une fois tous les jeunes qui
montent et descendent ou pas loin
la césure patate eu chaud même etienne
et patati schumi a même vu d'armé wangen
timoney petite monnaie mais acheter
quelque chose à bouffer pourra
maintenant mon temps voilà comment
étaient ils vivants
ensuite jean yves a réussi à construire
sa petite case et depuis il vivote
mais ces dernières années avec ses
problèmes de santé sa situation est
devenue très difficile
trois noms ne vivent comme ça que ça ou
espèrent ils tant que donne tu prends
évidemment des gens à wanted vie de
famille quoi
les mules du pape en une demoiselle de
me mettre dans mon tour de gila bouffer
la vie et maintenant il faut il est en
colère en colère maintenant non
mais je suis pas au dessus comme un mur
au soir mais on trouve les ajuste oui
mon coin juste
amusez-vous à aujourd'hui manager dans
la main et à l'épaule
on me diabaté soyez bon batman soyez bon
de tout le monde
sur le fond rien sur le terrain
parce qu'un harmonisé pour la douleur
mais l'annoncé parle pas de douleur
message bien reçu
l'association momon papa lé là a décidé
de venir en aide à jean yves
elle lance aujourd'hui un appel à la
solidarité argent matériaux et coup de
main sont les bienvenus
objectif offrir à jean-yves une nouvelle
case pour qu'il connaisse enfin autre
chose que la misère
[Musique]